liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger man
2018 war echt ein scheiß ja das war es
von mir was das reicht nicht als
neujahrsansprache also gut 2009 10 kann
eigentlich nur besser werden war echt
kein tolles jahr in der politik gab es
viele abschiede und die machen mir
eigentlich immer spaß aber 2018 wurde
wirklich jeder politiker durch einen
noch schlimmeren ersetzt martin schulz
durch andrea nahles seehofer durch
seiner angela merkel durch ak
so kann ich nicht arbeiten soll ich mir
jetzt über kramp karrenbauer auf reden
die ist so langweilig ich dran mich über
den ich auf regen und seehofer den ich
echt gern komplett verabschiedet hätte
bleibt innenminister
er kann einfach nicht gehen solange
merkel noch da ist
er hält es auch im neuen jahr mit luther
selbst wenn morgen die welt untergeht
würde ich heute noch angela merkel die
bremsschläuche durchschneiden und diesel
diese kann man bald auch nicht mehr
fahren kleiner tipp für den
jahreswechsel
ich habe an meinem diesel eine genial
einfache und billige hardware
nachrüstung vorgenommen mit dem ich die
emissionen auf null senken
ich habe die karte angezündet aber keine
angst aus umweltschutzgründen natürlich
nicht in meinem garten sondern im garten
von andreas scheuer was mich echt
gefreut hat hans-georg maßen wurde als
chef gefeuert jetzt ist unser
geheimdienst bestimmt weniger recht
der war gut und was war das bitteschön
vereinbart meter hochwasser im januar
niedrigwasser im herbst und diese hitze
mir ist dieses jahr klar geworden wie
schlimm die folgen des klimawandels
jetzt schon sind renate ist die ganze
zeit im bikini durch den garten getanzt
und was war noch ach ja der wolf ist
wieder da wild lebende wölfe besiegeln
niedersachsen und alle kriegen panik 75
mein gott jetzt kriegt euch mal wieder
ein jahr hosenscheißer ein paar wölfe
und lass doch der natur mal ihren lauf
[Musik]
wer hat die tür zum studio ausgelassen
frohes neues jahr
chance
[Musik]